Haley wants to know what is your
response to brands looking for 24/7
community management is it worth the
investment is it overkill you know Haley
I'm a big fan I believe that everybody
that you engage with and say hello to I
believe that everybody I said thanks to
or T Y over the weekend for watching all
21 episodes of this show get affected by
that I do think the human investment
matters I do think that if brands
committed more to one-on-one marketing
that many of them don't think is
scalable they would get bigger depth we
talked in the last episode about depth
and width a lot of you responded to that
I think the community managed to 24/7
can be valuable if you're big enough you
have to be a global brand you have to be
a Pepsi you have to be a Toyota to
really get the value out of 24/7 because
otherwise you're paying people to sit
around and not engage within you I'm not
crushing it on Twitter between 2:00 a.m.
Eastern and 6 a.m. Eastern so I don't
need anybody in which in this case is me
engaging there but if you're big enough
I believe in it